Hi everyone, my name is Briana Frank
and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
Let's talk about IBM Cloud Satellite.
Today, many enterprises are benefiting from using
public cloud to build and run their applications.
Being able to consume IT as a service, through
APIs, at scale, and as needed has transformed how
applications are built. Public Cloud enabled
companies to innovate in new, faster ways.
But the reality is only somewhere between
5% and 20% of enterprise workloads have moved
to the cloud. That first wave of applications
were focused mostly on new workloads
or workloads that can easily relocate.
Many applications have requirements around
security, compliance, latency, regulation,
and performance that mean those workloads can't
easily move into a public cloud.Enterprises need
an ability to gain the benefits of public cloud
anywhere they need their applications to run.
What would help these enterprises is
something called Distributed Cloud.
Distributed cloud is a new cloud computing
model that extends public cloud services
to any location. This means companies
can now run not only in their primary
cloud provider's infrastructure but on
premises, in other cloud providers',
in third party data centers or colocation
centers, or at the edge - in factories,
distribution centers, stores, hospitals
and ports - with everything managed from a
single control plane. IBM Cloud Satellite is
our new distributed cloud capability.With
Satellite you can take advantage of the
catalog of services from IBM cloud with
industry optimized security and compliance
and leading AI capabilities anywhere you
need it. All with a common API, user experience,
management dashboard and user consumption model.
To see how IBM Cloud Satellite works, let’s
take a look at a couple of real-world examples.
We’ll start with the financial services
industry. On the surface, the financial
services industry might seem like it's all about
money, but it's really all about technology.In
order to compete, financial institutions
need to create exceptional user experiences.
To do that, they leverage AI and trading
algorithms to stay ahead of the market.
To be competitive financial services clients
need to iterate quickly and leverage cloud-native
tools and best practices. However, the financial
industry is heavily regulated. So, they need to
be able to keep that data secure and compliant
- which often means there are restrictions on
where that data can live. IBM Cloud Satellite
can help solve this conflict. These financial
services companies can now extend public cloud
services in their data centers, allowing them
to leverage cloud native best practices and meet
their security and compliance obligations, all at
the same time. So, Satellite enables you to take
advantage of a public cloud consumption model,
but in many different locations - and you don't
have to be an expert in running these software
stacks to run them outside of the public
cloud. Let's take a look at another example,
this time in the construction
industry, where worker safety is key.
One of our clients is leveraging distributed
analytics to keep workers safe.
In this scenario, you might have a business, or
an office building that is under construction,
and you need to be able to leverage video
analytics to tell if someone is wearing a hard
hat or not - and warn them before they move into
a potentially dangerous area of that building.
They want to use video analytics to
automatically detect this situation,
but latency could be a real problem - if you
warn someone too late they could be injured.
So, let's take a look at how
this scenario might work.
To solve this safety problem, you need to be able
to analyze video data from many cameras all over
the office building, but it's impractical to send
all of that data back to the cloud to be processed
remotely.It would be better if the video
processing happened close to the actual device.
Traditionally, that would require you to install
servers and software and manage them on-prem.
With IBM Cloud Satellite, we can extend
the public cloud into the office,
so we can leverage cloud services to run
this application close to the device - and
that's critical in ensuring that we can
reduce latency and effectively warn someone
before they enter a dangerous
area.That same client in this
worker safety scenario had to adjust to
challenges brought by the Covid pandemic.
They were able to quickly iterate on
their application and modify the use-case.
Now, instead of warning workers about
wearing hard hats, they can make sure
that workers are wearing masks and ensure
that the masks are being worn correctly.
They can even leverage thermal devices to
take temperatures. With IBM Cloud Satellite,
you can quickly address unforeseen challenges,
leverage cloud benefits in any location,
and innovate quickly. Anytime. Anywhere. thank you
for watching if you have questions please drop us
a line below if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and subscribe